le gouvernement britannique n'a pas
perdu une seconde pour vanter les
mérites du brésil dans la réussite de sa
campagne de vaccination cette réussite
permet à boris johnson de faire oublier
les critiques sur sa gestion de la
pandémie
tout commence en janvier 2020 alors que
l'europe regarde encore le corona virus
se répandre en chine au royaume uni une
équipe de chercheurs se penchent déjà
sur la conception d'un vaccin
quelques mois plus tard l'astra zeneca
élancée est dès le mois de mai 2020 le
gouvernement britannique achète 100
millions de doses de ce vaccin et pour
le gouvernement c'est grâce au brésil
grâce aux briques site
nous avons pu prendre une décision
fondée sur le régulateur britannique un
régulateur de classe mondiale et non
rythme des européens qui avance un peu
plus lentement
nous faisons tous les mêmes contrôles de
sécurité et suivant les mêmes procédures
mais nous avons pu accélérer la manière
dont ils sont faits grâce aux briques
site
alors que la vaccination patinent sur le
continent européen le gouvernement
britannique assure ne pas être affectés
par les retards de livraison et pour
cause
le régulateur britannique des
médicaments avait été le premier à
donner son feu vert au vaccin fighter en
décembre 2020 grâce à une procédure
d'urgence permettant à londres de passer
une commande de 367 millions de doses et
donc est d'être le premier sur la liste
bien avant que les européens commencent
à faire des réserves est le royaume uni
signent des contrats plus détaillée mais
moins formalisées que l'union européenne
avec astrazeneca pfizer biotech novavax
et john seine avec une avance de trois
mois sur bruxelles avec un risque tout
de même aucune efficacité n'avait encore
été prouvée à cette époque et le
gouvernement britannique n'hésite pas à
se féliciter
je suis absolument ravi de vous dire que
nous avons maintenant vacciner la moitié
de tous les adultes au royaume uni c'est
un énorme succès c'est tellement
important car ce vaccin est notre seul
moyen de sortir de cette pandémie
le programme de vaccination britannique
est une grande réussite
c'est grâce au travail acharné de
nombreuses personnes
ce n'est pas facile mais nous faisons
des progrès considérables
autre facteur de cette réussite
l'instauration de la uk vaccine task
force une unité gouvernementale charge
les vaccins avec à la tête et kate
bingham biochimiste spécialisées dans le
capital risque sans expérience en
matière de vaccins elle négocie et
sécurise les doses selon elle c'est
l'agilité et la coopération du
gouvernement qui a permis de dépasser
les états unis et l'union européenne
des procédures décrié par les voisins
européens il faut noter qu'il y à
différentes procédures et approche les
états unis et le royaume uni ont opté
pour des autorisations d'utilisation
d'urgence alors que nous avons préféré
l'approchent conditionnelle normal
recourant à une procédure est prouvé ce
qui peut conduire à quelques différences
de calendrier
l'important n'est pas d'être le premier
mais d'avoir un vaccin sûr et efficace
cela fait donc cinq mois déjà que
royaume uni et l'union européenne ont
divorcé et cinq ans que le référendum du
breakbeat a eu lieu pour le moment le
royaume uni savoure sa séparation
selon un sondage réalisé par bloomberg
en avril dernier et les britanniques
sont 67% à penser que l'indépendance du
royaume uni et la raison du succès de la
campagne vaccinale
le gouvernement continue donc sur sa
lancée d'ici septembre
boris johnson espère que toute la
population sera vaccinée